all right look finding your favorite
products and discovering new ones
requires a user interface that's easy to
use informative clear and delightful
google cloud users have mainly used our
side menu to navigate but with almost
100 products and growing it's safe to
say our product list has outgrown the
side menu
over time we have listened to your
feedback and some of you have
highlighted challenges navigating the
console to explore our products we've
heard over and over again that it's
difficult and time consuming to scroll
through the long list of products and
remember what each one offers
so that's why we created a new all
products page to help you easily
navigate to your favorite google cloud
products this page showcases all of the
google cloud products as well as our key
partner products in one easy to navigate
place with one click you can discover
the right product that's right for your
solution
the page is organized into different
categories including management compute
storage operations security ci cd
artificial intelligence support and more
quickly jump to the category of interest
through the panel on the left or you can
scroll the entire page then you can
click each product name to navigate
directly to the product homepage each
product listing also includes a short
and long description so you can quickly
understand what a product does and
whether it fits your needs
this lets you compare categories at a
glance saving you the hassle of digging
up product overviews elsewhere
under each product you'll also find a
link to documentation and quick starts
so you can understand it in more depth
and try it out right away removing the
extra step of navigating to
documentation in another tab
to make navigation even easier you can
pin products directly from the all
products page and they'll show up at the
top of your side menu you can also
customize your navigation by reordering
pins in the side menu that way you can
quickly access your most used products
directly from the side menu instead of
scrolling through the panel or the all
products page
with the new all products page you can
save time scrolling and cut straight to
the good stuff finding your products
discovering new ones learning and
getting hands-on so try it out for
yourself by heading to the google cloud
console click the side panel and click
view all products or on the home
dashboard you'll see a call out to try
out the all products page
if you have any feedback about this new
experience i actually want to hear so
reach out to me on twitter at steph r
underscore wong or on linkedin at
stephar wong see you there